so much breathing room with that intro
since oh man feeling man I'm feeling
good how are you man after a long
weekend at Tiger Woods golf and some NC
double-a basketball it's good to be back
I didn't watch much Tiger this weekend I
watch more last weekend it was cool I
watched like the last few holes of Rory
McIlroy to see him kind of close it up
nice to see it was nice I wonder if I
always wonder like if all those guys
games are gonna pop up now again because
the Tigers back and it's almost gonna
make them like refighters
collected we guessed right the Crouching
Tiger Hidden Dragon Tiger is back man we
need to get on her game so I'm out and
I'm watching the the bracket games on
Friday night and Jude came up to me and
he's like yo man what's up I love the
podcast my all its kraid he goes you
know how do you have your quarterbacks
ranked and I was like I don't know man
like I just kind of trust Sims and I and
that's like I wasn't even planning on
starting to talk about this like we're
gonna we're gonna talk about in Dhamma
consumer gonna talk about the Jets cold
trade but I really want to talk about
Sam Darnell yeah okay because every mock
draft I look at I'm looking at like
Bucky Brooks right here and sand
Arnold's going number one to the rounds
and and this guy cuz if he gives you you
know like Sam darn 'old and he actually
said I don't like sand Arnold either
right and that's what I hear from a lot
of people and you said something before
we just started recording that I just
want to get out there right away yeah
sure fine yeah I mean I'm amazed by this
Sam darn 'old he's the automatic number
one pick as well
I really am I mean it's it's kind of
like everywhere you go it's like old
Arnold's going one or two
so I guess my issue is this are you
hearing that well that first of all you
know I don't think he's worth that from
my evaluation
yeah it's really good he's a first
rounder he's certainly in the
conversation yes do I look at him as the
number one or to pick in the draft
certainly not no but this is where it
gets conflicting to me not only you know
with my friends around in football I
don't none of my friends have Sam
Dharma's the number one quarterback in
the coming out and that's a good amount
of people that's a pretty good group of
guys with your
crow oh look at these fancy graphics cut
the left go stay on your point though
but yes the none of my friends are
sitting there going oh no Sam Darnell is
the number oh I talk to a lot of
quarterback coaches and offensive
coordinators let me get in your heads
thank you you're tall about exchanging
information with these guys and you're
going we're knocking Bob and you're like
where do you have Sam to Arnold right
like or do you agree with what these
mock tracks are saying and then what do
they say well they're all have their
concerns as well so they're I can't tell
you none of my friends know ones that
people know about like I haven't talked
to Kyle about the quarterback situation
okay just so we can get in that
conversation yes he drove to that kid
from Iowa last year so I'm not a Rob
Lowe so he's not deep into the
quarterback conversation anyways but
like other friends that I have yes
none of them have gone now Donald's
number one for me I mean none you
haven't heard oh and then even to add on
to that again we're still at the early
stages like I've told people to like I
don't fell teams I don't know if they
really know who's number one yet that's
great this is where people have to go
yeah because this is where it starts
linked I know I'm a fan and I am rooting
for a team that's making hundreds of
millions of dollars a year yeah and
while I can't pay attention to the
quarterbacks all the time because it's
not my job right says everybody else
right these team surely should be
they're investing their future how do
they not know what you know valuators
might know or think they know but I
don't think offensive coordinators and
quarterback coaches have done finishing
their evaluations yet okay so like when
it comes to the combine especially now
that the draft is late April sometimes
the first week in May guys just going to
the combine and go let me watch a quick
highlight tape just to get a feel for
the player so when I meet them I can at
least know what his skill set is but
they haven't broken him down until after
the combine it's gonna be real so
Darnell didn't throw out the combine
he's throwing on Wednesday right it's
supposed to rain he's going to still
throw Wednesday that'd be interesting
really because one of my issues with
Darnell - of course just seeing him in
person as well you know I don't love his
body of course the motion is a little
bit concerning to me but the other thing
that was concerning to me when I watched
him on film or saw him in person at
Notre Dame as if you told me the
footballs he threw were from 19
anyone I would go yeah they look like
the other day right so what does that
mean that means that the ball is broken
into a way to where he is love with it
the way it feels so it's optimal for the
way it feels and grips for him so you're
not gonna get that type of football the
time in the NFL
let me explain to people that have
joined our podcasts that are not
listening to us Sims is a weirdo when he
told Leba tarred and stugots that he is
a studier of men's bodies he's not
kidding
he'll look at me and be like Oh took the
week off huh he just observes things
like that and when it comes to footballs
and quarterbacks yeah grymps he'll watch
film and go oh that's a cool bandana and
I'm like I don't know what you're
talking about but when you go to the
football field you observe things that I
would never see and one of them is the
type of football and you said Sam darn
old was throwing something that looks
like it got thrown off over the fence it
looks like you looked at you know you
went into the left go family closet
right huh
I found my lucky my favorite seventh
grade yes and as we've said all the time
which went back to the whole Tom Brady
deflate thing everyone's very particular
yes but if you go to the NFL that ain't
happening they're not gonna get a full I
don't believe you can do that in college
yeah no college there's no rules for
stuff like that there's you know you can
bring any football you want yeah I mean
yes I mean as long as they throw the the
air pressure's fine whatever else it
doesn't matter how old how new whatever
it is yeah there's no rules so that is
something I watch out watch for of
course but just to end that conversation
again I'm not sitting here there's some
things Darnell does that I really do
like again yeah I just have this issue
with that he's the slam dunk number one
I don't get because I've also called
some of my friends who were like NFL
insiders right who know more people than
I know around the NFL and none of them
can give me an answer to go oh no
Donald's the consensus number one favor
here yes
they're in the same boat like now it's
still too early i nobody's put like a
stamp of approval on anybody yet so that
to me just tells me then the darn old
thing is just a media pigmentation at
this point is that the proper use of
that word no I don't know well I figure
is not a word pigmentation and a figment
of their imagination maybe that's what I
was looking for
that's what
I think we're gonna start we are going
to start invented Sims work right I
thought about this last week I think it
and we're gonna start with figment a
segmentation that's amazing I just
wanted to start there because when I was
looking at the Jets Colts trade that
happened this weekend by the way hello
everybody thank you for subscribing on
iTunes as always check out at Sims Lefko
but all of a sudden I got new updated
mock draft of the third pic and I was
like oh man this is great and all of
them were like Sam darn 'old one and I
was like men that's interesting maybe
the Browns maybe people already know
that the Browns like Sam Darnell I mean
you made a good few Jackson points well
he has the USC ties I mean yes he's he's
an alum so I'm not sure but he's got USC
ties but doesn't look at listening to
you anymore
yeah Hughes not calling any shots
they're not then the new John Dorsey
that came in he goes hey oh and sixteen
huge accent build my team for me tell me
how to work none what it's one in 31 131
so again no I don't think he has added
to that conversation when people said oh
you know he Hugh Jackson recommended AJ
McCarron to the Buffalo Bills
well that just tells you to that he
probably want him to come to Cleveland
but they said you don't have that choice
the Cleveland thing other to it just end
that conversation yeah I mean I doubt
Hugh was calling the shots there they
got a read we got to remember who was
there now Todd Haley's there right with
a John Dorsey oh right Todd Haley is
he's more from the Bill Parcells Bill
Belichick school of quarterbacks Big Ben
the Tom Brady's of the world the Matt
castles do we add in Kansas City to me
that guy would be Josh Allen so if you
made me connect the dots right now I
would go Cleveland would pick Josh Allen
and I think at this part of the process
Josh Allen as much as I love Lamar
Jackson
I think post combine all that everything
is sauce economy he'd probably be my
number one at this point too
I'm realizing with all of this there is
this world that is created around the
draft that has upset me for a very long
time as someone that used to be upset
with a draft and that's none of this
matters that's what I'm realizing
so what happens is is we've now made
Leigh the fact and when I say this I
love our own Matt Miller and Matt works
really hard I'm not talking about Matt
right I'm talking about
they're people with her hey it's Mach
7.0 mach 2.0 didn't matter I don't think
it doesn't matter the whole thing - is
the Jets traded all these picks to move
up to the Colts but if they get their
guy
none of those picks matter right that's
not [ __ ] true because they gave up
the three second round picks and when a
few years ago the the they moved up for
dion jordan they gave up one I
understand what they're saying when you
get a quarterback then that's great
but this whole thing about the draft it
just doesn't matter and our jobs are
fine and draft guys never have to own up
to anything like the Mel Kiper thing
still upset oh I get you they work hard
I give them that it's hard to place it
out I know that we gonna get in this
Jess
okay so V that was all over the place
the Jets gave up the sixth round six
pick in the draft 37 49 and next year's
to to move up to the third pick in the
draft with the Indianapolis Colts um
this goes back to the Hugh Jackson thing
yeah I went mmm the disease of doubt has
already crept in for me I don't trust
you Jackson because you're won in 31 I
don't trust what all the stuff you have
going on there yeah I'm going to trust
that this front office for the Jets can
draft quarterbacks I know after a petty
and Hackenberg write it's a little
concerning I mean especially Hackenberg
yes I get you now they'll approval yeah
I know and I always say this mechag Ninh
I think was totally you know sold on
Hackenberg because a Billy O'Brien
coming to Texas
the Texans the year after Hackenberg
freshman year where he coached a
kannberg there and I think that just
lived in mechag man's head forever I'm
sure that know Bill O'Brien came down
there and he said this is a first-round
quarterback and he never could get over
that in his mind and when I say move is
to get a quarterback I mean yes I would
hope so yeah I mean to me you're crazy
if you gave up all that inventory of
picks to take a running back this day
Nate who I love c'est quoi party he is
worthy of the number one pick
but I also would add to that in this day
and age to give up that man
picks where we just saw the leading NFL
Russia as a fourth round pick
album kumara coming to the league the
year before that Jordan Howard was a
fourth round pick he was the second
leading rusher in football Alfred Morris
was second leading and rushing use a
sixth round pick
trading up now not knowing who's gonna
be available at three I do okay I I do
like it now I know a lot of people
giving them flack right for trading up
now this price is only gonna get more
expensive as we get closer means if you
call back later they go oh sorry no
we're gonna need more we're gonna need a
fourth alright I mean as it starts to
clear its picture I mean you just don't
know so they got in the spot now and
they'll see where they go from here but
you got a guess who they want no I mean
I've it to me this is the thing that I
just come to the realization I don't
know I mean I really don't know who the
hell they like it's really who do you
think's in their top three that's really
what it comes down to us who's in their
top three guys right that is where Baker
I'm just kidding what do you think I
think Baker Mayfield certainly in their
top three and I think Josh outlets in
their top three I would think Josh
Allen's in everybody's top three okay
just because of size your team is Josh
Lamar Jackson and Baker yes right and
would you say that's their top three or
is a little more probably not I don't
know how yeah I don't know how everybody
evaluates from Lamar
here's the wild coffee is the wild card
yes because I yes I know people around
the NFL that seem Lamar the same way I
do and they really have yeah so you have
more people in the NFL saying that they
believe Lamar Jackson has the talent of
a top pick right and Sam darn old has
the talent I some of my friends yes I've
given more of the stamp of approval to
Lamar Jackson than Sam Donald yeah this
isn't because you've like convinced them
no no I mean these are friends that I
would push back against me if they saw
me they don't care like they like to
hear my opinion and we talk ball but if
they disagree they're very confident in
where they are in life yes so I have no
qualms with that back in there no
there's this the the darn old thing
again is interesting just because it's
such a raw film to I mean he's the worst
in the pocket he takes care of the ball
the worst I mean all those things I
would say he leaves the most down the
field throws open out of all the guys
because if the first guys that open he
runs around
just tries to make a play with his
athleticism I think the big winner of
the trade is the Browns the big one are
the trades definitely the Browns because
now if you go quarterback we're not sure
what the Giants are gonna do but we know
that there's a quarterback coming at
three you're gonna get either a sake one
or a Bradley Chubut for now guaranteed
pretty much pretty much yes I'm having a
hard time looking at the Giants at
number two watching the rest of the NFL
punch themselves in the face to get up
into this high tier level of quarterback
to get their guy for the future and
they're sitting there with a set 37 year
old Eli Manning yeah whose football
teams have not scored over 30 points
even though Odell Beckham was on the
roster for two like two and a half years
and they're not gonna take a quarterback
I don't think they've answered that
question yet I mean to me it just well I
just I don't know these things but I
just think there's there's a lot of dots
that connect here with the Giants
situation first of all I do feel like
they're kind of in like we want to win
right now mode right so that makes me
believe that they could very easily take
a sake want to or they could trade down
and go you know we'll go to seven or
eight or nine whatever it is and try to
go Quentin Nelson and fill out our
problems because now if the bills want
to move up right they got to get ahead
of the Jets at two right so they mean
that would be the perfect trade partner
the New York Giants certainly but at the
same time I think if I'm running the
Giants I'm going man I'm not sure when
I'll have the number two pick in the
draft ever again and I could set up my
franchise for the next 12 years so you
might just have to bite the bullet and
go you know what I'm gonna waste this
number to pick and take a quarterback
even though he's gonna sit behind Eli
Manning for a year or two whatever it
may be but it's the greater good for the
next ten years of the organization they
are in a money spot right now I mean to
me sake if they wanted to win right now
say Kwan's the guy I mean you put say
Quon with Eli and Odell Beckham jr. on
the Romans trailing Shepard Luck right
[ __ ] good luck covering those guys
and they will say those are all the
people to say yeah the Giants haven't
had a good o line there to guard their
garden center just got paid 90 million
dollars combined the agent market so
apparently the rest of the NFL thought
those guys I mean and Eric Flowers is I
mean any grading surface
I know he's topped these top half of the
NFL I know it's a it's a it's a theme
that the the Eli Manning backers here in
New York just went with the old lines
horrible we got to change it even though
it's maybe this top three centers in
football and one of the better guards in
football and all that but what do you
think the Buffalo Bills are thinking I
just want to finish the jam the Jets
though trading the number three - they
got to be sitting there and just at the
very worst going were ok with these
three quarterbacks no matter who they
are whether that's John Rosen an Allen
or Mayfield Rosen and Arnold I just
can't imagine being happy with your
third choice well this is a year there I
don't think everybody's threes gonna be
everybody's three like it's gonna be
beauty in the eye of the beholder it's
gonna be a little bit about the offense
you run and how you envision that
quarterback fitting into it so no matter
who you get at the press coverage you go
this is the guy we wanted all along
yeah this is the one people didn't say
it the way we did so every GM's gonna
sound like a genius
these are West Coast guys Jeremy Bates
right Jeremy Bates Jon Gruden school of
thought that those kind of guys I think
they're gonna Aaron I don't think Rosen
will be in there talk like for me if you
made me just bet I don't know I think
it's going to be probably a Mayfield
Allen darn old conversation for the Jets
at 3:00 [ __ ] it we're doing something I
didn't plan on yeah we're doing a top
five mock draft right now right now
Kevin the first pick in the NFL Draft
Josh Brown select Josh Allen you know
huffed you don't get to make that pick
you did it beforehand
Josh Allen's number one Giants come up
man with the second selection and then a
full draft the New York Giants elect -
should I do this as in what I would do
is there or should've what I think they
know do you want to know I don't know
it's really if I'm the Giants and I want
to take Seco on Berkeley and just go
let's go try to put a Super Bowl this
year let's go do you think they can with
Eli yes
you think they can I do think if they
got sake one and they got a Legault goal
tree you think that they can win the
Super Bowl this year eat with that
offensive line yeah I do I think there
would be okay only do I don't I don't
have any issue their team is a lot more
talented than
their final roster showed Shermer
certainly gonna make the offense better
you know like tomatillo gel that I like
James better a defensive coordinator
yeah don't be shocked as the Giants are
back in this convo certainly I mean it's
just too much talent on the team and
with the third pick in the NFL Draft the
New York Jets now have I'm gonna say
Baker Mayfield yeah I really think I
guess if you put me to where I just
think it's gonna go right now I'm gonna
say I like one stop I'm okay we're doing
this okay I was gonna just go I think if
I think what's going to happen like that
instead of what I would want to do like
I think right now it's just shaping up
to be if I was just it seems like it's
Allen one Darnell two Mayfield three and
then say Kwan for our time out you're
really confusing me
so were you currently doing what you
think they're going to do or what you
would do well I change it for a second
whatever yeah dammit alright so you were
doing what you think they're gonna do
which is Josh Allen Berkeley Baker and
then who the Browns take that was my
hoping what they would do oh this your
open okay then finish that one who do
you have it for for you're hoping they
would do for the Browns at four that
would be sake one they already took sake
on it - oh the Giants we're doing the
Hobie whoa you've confused this that
completely chub this is what you get for
stupid [ __ ] like this okay well we're
gonna change the show and do a mock
draft right now just cuz I want it yeah
it was fun no okay screw your mock draft
okay and confusing everything I think if
it's gonna go the way it's gonna go
right now I'm gonna take sake wants to
go to the Cleveland Browns it for you're
gonna go Allen one it's gonna go darn
'old - to the Giants it's gonna go
number three may feel - the Jets
Berkeley for - the Cleveland Browns and
then Broncos the Broncos at five are
going to take Bradley Chubb and then
with von Miller not your eyebrows just
go up I just thought this thing that
makes too much sense how are they gonna
pass him by you know Shane Ray has not
quite been what they wanted - he's been
injured you know he kind of he's an
outside linebacker defense and hybrid I
could certainly see that happening yes
and then at six would be the Colts and
that's I could be Minka Fitzpatrick who
I haven't got to evaluate yet that could
be a guard why didn't you just put
Darnell and the Giants at time
throwing things I'm just trying to
connect the dots of [ __ ] that I've
read out there when I would do this is
not Chris Simms mock draft I'm just
saying the way it lies right now and the
stuff I hear that's just my feeling I
will say this in terms of money and the
Jets so the Jets are paying Germaine
Johnson 26 million dollars next season
yeah
the Rams here you were talking about the
Giants going all in to try and win the
Rams for 25 million dollars next season
are paying Aqib Talib Marcus Peters Sam
Shields and LaMarcus Joyner they get all
four of those guys for 25 and tremaine's
getting paid 26 yeah that just shows you
the value right we could do this on the
Packers as well by cutting Jordy Nelson
the Packers freed up more than ten
million dollars with that more than ten
million dollars they can afford Jimmy
Graham and Mohammad Wilkerson's contract
next season right so you need to look at
it from afar sometimes to go look at all
the stuff we're getting Mike Pouncy
dolphins it came out it was not a
character thing that's not the reason
they got rid of him
but they were able to pay Josh sittin
and Kilgore the same salary that he got
they got two for the price of one right
just good GME it is good GM jamming what
else did you want to talk about anything
else there no I just you just you [ __ ]
me over the drafts all right you [ __ ]
yourself I guess but that's the problem
with the dress is it what is it what you
think they're gonna do when I do it all
Tim might not stamp my name to it and
tell you that this is the way I think
it's gonna go down there's the mock
draft of Chris Sims style right now it's
so early I'm just trying to connect dots
I mean again I'll throw in another
wrinkle of that conversation
I mean Cleveland at number four there's
conversations that they're gonna
renegotiate with Duke Duke Johnson and
Rhee sign him and they just gave 15
million dollars to Carlo side so that
you tell me they're gonna take it
running back at number four - I mean
what are they gonna have 30 million
dollars worth of running backs on their
roster man so that's where I get
confused with this conversation as well
I will say this though they can kind of
do that because their entire like team
is filled on rookie contracts yeah yeah
it's not about them money have so much
money to spend they do yes and it really
does
matter where it goes the number one free
agent that is still left right now is in
Dhamma consume and donek ensue it
appears our good friend Jordan Schultz
has now he's been reporting on it he's
been calling Hsu all the time and have
you ever gotten called by Schultz he is
persistent so sue is like Jordan leave
me alone but it's down to four teams it
is down to the Titans the Saints the
Seahawks and the Rams he's visiting the
Rams if he goes to Seattle he's close to
his original home of Portland he goes to
a team that is kind of being gutted and
he says he cares more about winning the
money so I don't know if the Seahawks
are ready to win but you do have Russell
Wilson yes the Rams Wow
yeah Rams are ready to win right and
endowment can sue and Aaron Donald on
the same D line with with Talib and
Peters and LaMarcus Joyner could be the
greatest defensive tackle duo ever and
the history of the sport in the history
of the sport yeah I meant I name me two
better D tackles than that together
right there to - I mean right now
borrowing any crazy injuries -
first-ballot Hall of Famers I mean that
that's how good they whole thing is if
Reggie White ever lined up inside with
your hombre right right some of those
there right certainly yeah maybe for
purple people eaters the original roads
closed right the Steel Curtain there's
certainly some there yeah I think you
have to go back to that yes as special
the Saints yeah very much ready to win
now right it's funny because they
actually brought in Nick what's-his-face
that was on the line next farily Nick
Fairley right yeah the hard conditions
but if he goes there that's a game
changer change and they're doing good
things on the defensive side of the ball
Bri signed Alex Okafor got some more
guys Davis and middle Patrick Robinson
and then the Titans yeah which I think
now that you have Malcom Butler and
Logan Ryan and they have Dori Jackson of
course adore Jackson but if the D
lineman that we've been pumping up for
the last few years
Tyrell Casey throughout Casey sure the
Titans are like hey look we're in a
pretty good division it's a little bit
young but where do you think su goes and
where would you advise him to go oh the
Tennessee Titan thing
I would not go to Seattle if I'm done
with this I agree I mean I just feel
like it's a there a little bit and turn
over the roster mode it's iffy for me it
also just doesn't even make sense to me
from the standpoint of like Seattle
seems like they're trying to get rid of
their older disgruntled out smoking
stars and then they're gonna bring in
like the king disgruntled star in town
Rams Saints or Titans I don't know if
money's equal everywhere right he said
it's hard to write he said he didn't
even talk money right his Saints and
Titans because he cares more about
culture and winning right I mean the the
Titans culture with Vrabel and Dean
Pease Adi coordinator and Matt Lafleur
is the OC I mean I just really think
that's a team that's on the rise but I
would also say the Rams with Sean McCray
and Wade filler they're a little closer
oh they're all awesome I mean and the
Saints are the coins the best yes yes
they're the clay and they they could
probably use him more than anybody else
all right so where do you think he goes
I think he's gonna go to the Rams Wow I
think he's gonna go star power I think
he's gonna go Wade Phillips in LA just
you know I just think that was last year
you know he likes that aspect of it yeah
that's just the one that to me it just
seems to make the most sense that
defense will be insane evil insane Wow
I'm legitimately worried as an Eagles
fan yeah you should be they get him
they're gonna be in the conversations
for the the favorite - don't win the
Super Bowl or at least one of the
favorites to get there
did you see how dramatic that pause was
I thought I was gonna be like like David
Lee the chance to be okay all right so
that will be obviously interesting to
see with sue another defensive lineman
Sheldon Richardson signs a one-year deal
with the Vikings and I think in terms of
talent this was actually bigger for the
Vikings than going from Case Keenum
to Kirk Cousins I think getting a guy
like Sheldon Richardson on the Vikings
d-line where we know they've been
insanely shallow and they haven't like
they've had some talent but those guys
Everson Griffin have been expected to do
so much
I think is a huge move for Sheldon they
still need depth though on that yeah
there's only thing that worried me about
the Kirk Cousins conversation yeah we
you and I have talked about the Vikings
defensive front fizzling out at the end
of the last two seasons and that's true
I mean look at Everson Griffin's sack
production some of the guys individual
production altogether yeah just lacks
because they're on the field too much
Sheldon Richardson though they needed
that legit three technique they never
really got that you got Linville Joseph
who's truly a he's a shade nose a nose
tackle they wanted the other kid sharif
Lloyd Wright the first rounder from a
few years ago to be that three technique
three technique for people I'll try and
simplify it tell me if I'm right yeah
somebody that lines up over a gap and he
is trying to get to the quarterback
Warren Sapp being the epitome of the
three jerk right Aaron Donnelly similar
where Linville Joseph tries to absorb
people right he's going strangely lines
up like over the center the three
technique just for all use out there is
the outside shoulder of the guard that's
that's basically with the tackle the
tackle son yeah they're both there's
tactics on each side but yes the outside
shoulder that is your three I think he's
the piece they've been missing I do
think he's certainly gonna help them
tremendously because guys like shamar's
Stevens and Linville Joseph are like the
same guys they're more of that true nose
tackle where he's a little bit more like
you said gap speed predicated create
chaos get upfield adds a little depth to
their team overall yeah I mean it
improves them and you'll watch out for
the Vikings so I see the Vikings
improving I see the Rams I mean holy
crap if they get him improve yeah the
Patriots are coming and I don't think
people are realizing the moves that
bills making yeah now right now look
they've lost Nate's older they've lost a
lot of these guys Matthew Slater was out
meeting with the Steelers and that
really upset Patriots fans they get
Adrian Claiborne another depth guy which
I think it's gonna be good but the fact
that you're putting him next to Danny
Shelton you're just getting bigger
bodies angrier bodies on that line right
they signed Jeremy hill yeah so in
essence they're now just taking the
Bengals backfield for the last two
decades whether it's been Corey Dillon
or Rex Burkhead and now Jeremy hill he
just finds Bengals running back
the two trades though or what has me go
and watch out for Bill Belichick right
he swapped late round picks and got
cordarrelle Patterson yeah
swapped like a six for a five and they
were not even that far away and then he
did a six for a seven swap and got Jason
McCourty from the Browns he's getting
these players for free
like Jason McCourty the fact that we
have the McCourty twins in the same back
in the same defensive backfield and now
he has jeremy hill and cordarrelle
Patterson to play around with on the
offensive side right I think Patterson
is gonna be utilized so well with the
Patriots yeah well he's going to do what
Matthew Slater did he is brought in
there as truly it they're bringing him
in to be a special team star I would
think so not not do you see him being an
offensive weapon to use running back to
a degree but for a guy that we've talked
about struggling finding the intricacies
and nuances of certain passing offense
so I think he's gonna be a running back
yeah well he they're gonna use them
they're gonna use them in a lot of
different ways speed sweeps whatever it
may be yes but his main thing is going
to be returned kicks and he's phenomenal
and running down the field and making
tackles yes I would think he's going to
be their new version of their masters
Matthew Slater who can add some
offensive explosions yeah like you said
he mean he had some great runs last year
at the running back position touchdown
run against the jet up pairing up both
McCourty brothers yeah I mean Jason and
he starred opposite Stephon Gilmore
you're a little bit less excited I
thought you would be yes because Jason's
good not great and he's certainly a
little bit he's lost his straight ahead
explosion over the last just few years
there was a time where I was like man
Jason McCord he's better than Devin
McCourty start their careers I was like
I'm not so sure I wouldn't rather have
Jason because Jason was a true corner
and Devin was like every safety or
corner we weren't sure you know that's
an advantage doubt it is an advantage
and he's truly a safety that they just
used a corner with certain matchups but
no McCourty is gonna be great for them
in the sense that is he gonna be able to
be trusted on an island as much as an
amalgam Butler no but he's smart he does
everything right he tackles he does
everything he
it fits the New England way right off
the bat and I think that's why it makes
sense oh there was another cut that I'm
curious about oh by the way Orlando
Scandrick just signed with Washington
yes is awesome that stays in the the
division like that
Jonathan Hankins getting cut by the
Colts because of a scheme fit yeah did
he have a good year last year he was
good not great not what you saw not the
same guy soften the year but still a
huge monster yes he is and yeah they're
there they're gonna run the Cowboys
defense right that's who they got
Albertosaurus could never say his last
name Matt Alber first for the Colts yes
he's the gnudi coordinator from Dallas
it's a true four three type of scheme
it's a little more speed predicated
where Hankins job was a little bit more
of making my edge way yes exactly
yes right I mean so Hankins he's gonna
have suitors out there for sure but yes
he's like come on the Vikings throw him
in there he certainly can but I doubt
they're gonna have enough money to throw
it no I don't think so yeah
there is one other guy that's unsigned
Eric Ebron is making the rounds right
now but it's Eric Reid and this is going
to be interesting to watch it's gonna be
on your television a lot Eric Reid is
sort of the lesser-known Niner that
continued kneeling as Colin Kaepernick
got all of the headlines Eric Reid was
one of the final six or seven guys in
the entire NFL that continued to do it
week in and week out and as the season
was ending I saw it posted all over the
place it's gonna be really interesting
Eric Reid's a free agent Wonder for any
one's gonna pick him up mhmmm Eric Reid
kneeling again what everyone's gonna
pick him up I'm not gonna happen
Eric Reid all of the top free agents are
gone yeah and I'm not seeing Eric Reid
getting calls anywhere this is a pro
baller that can play safety corner or
linebacker in a league that is now
obsessed with players that can play
cornerback safety and linebacker and
he's getting zero calls so if he wants
to come play for the Eagles we're gonna
be happy to have them
we just don't got the money but it just
does it seems like we got another black
ball situation we do a course we do yes
the NFL wants to end this and part of
them ending
this is to stop the players who are at
the forefront of kneeling during the
national anthem again it does need to
end because it's not gonna help the
players at the end at the end of the day
it's not lit just like we're seeing with
Eric Reid like this is why I said we
needed to stop it
even though I'm all for the fight we
gotta find a new way the players have to
be more progressive and find another way
to fight it yeah because I don't want it
to continue I know I'm just I'm just
saying but yeah kneeling now we're
talking about we are talking about it
yeah but I mean for how much longer it's
just gonna continue to fizzle away fade
away whatever it may do you think anyone
in eventually signs this guy how about
this tell me where Eric Reid was last
year and whether or not he deserves to
be on another tee horse he does that's
not even a question of course he
deserves to be on another football team
yes that's that's a no-brainer it's
stupid he's being blackballed there's
gonna be no other way Herbert is he he
is he's starting caliber safety I'm not
gonna sit here and tell you he's one of
the 20 best safeties in the he made the
Pro Bowl because of his name a little
bit when he came out as a first-round
pick
LSU and and he's got the measurables he
has a lot of things he's has concussion
issues so that's gonna be a worry
worried thing worried something for
teams but is he one of the 10 best
safeties in football no but certainly
starting caliber and I do think he'll
find his way on the team it's just gonna
be that right time of a team finally
going ok we're a little desperate and we
can deal with the anthem protesting
thing and we'll bring them in here and
see if we can figure it out they're
gonna try to exhaust all other avenues
first before they have to be backed into
that corner well it's funny because the
team the Ravens when they came out it
seemed like they were gonna sign
Kaepernick and then their owner said you
know say prayers for us and you may end
up not signing him that team the Ravens
is into an in my mind some more slimy
practice yeah and there's a few things
that we stand for on this podcast and
number one being that we're in here for
the players and we think something slimy
happened and I just want to call it out
and that is that on march 13th and this
is all from Walter football who was
really good at chronicling this on
Twitter so shout out to him so about six
days ago on the eve of free agency they
signed Ryan Grant the Ravens did
- a nice contract two days later the
Raiders released michael crabtree then
two hours later the Ravens failed grants
physical making the contract void then
the next day
Baltimore gave almost all of that money
to Michael Crabtree just noting that
Ryan Grant whose physical was failed had
not failed a physical in four years so
they signed a guy because of this
tampering process it didn't go
officially through for the next two days
when it couldn't go through Crabtree got
released cuz they were gonna sign Jordy
and they went oh ingot Crabtree we're
gonna give him that money that's right
yeah it's shady as can be I don't even
know how its legal in the NFL I mean
yeah from what happened or at least from
what I've read Ozzie said he didn't get
the physical handed to him for like two
days somehow sure well they're gonna
spend on whoever way they want us yeah
to me it went down like this okay they
were getting ready to sign Ryan grant
giving him in this contract proposal and
Michael Crabtree's agent called or
somebody called like that and said hey
we just got word the Raiders are going
to release Crabtree yes they said oh
crap trees are kind of guy what she is
he fits perfectly with a rapist I mean
he seems like it and they yeah that's
all accounts it seems like a lowball
move that they pulled out of this deal
because they found another player at the
12th hour and I guess it's within their
rights to go sign a Michael Crabtree man
it's just gum buckets come buckets it's
gonna be interesting to see I'm not
sitting you're gonna tell you that
Michael Crabtree is like significantly
better and or even better than Ryan
granny either it's close I mean Ryan
Gretz good he's young he's more in the
prime of his career he was fired teeth
yes I would argue he can separate you
know one-on-one a little better than
Crabtree now Crabtree is bigger can
probably work the middle better can
catch more contested footballs that way
but yeah that was a lot that was a dirty
move by the Ravens does that impact so
obviously whoever riding Grant's age
represents it will impact all of those
right do those stories ever get out
though okay you guys need money yeah
exactly the players are [ __ ]
there's nothing you can do there's only
so much money out there this
conversation the Eric Reid conversation
it's like you guys have no passion no
power absolutely none no the only thing
that can help people like Eric Reid is
other superstars in the sport especially
being the quarterbacks would have to
stick up and make limelight of the
situation and then put pressure on teams
in the NFL to finally for them to go we
got to sign this guy make limelight make
a situation we got to today though
Crabtree will say is getting free crab
cakes for life buy in from a local
establishment and it goes well with
Crabtree yummy my question for you is
this
really I don't eat crab cakes so for
that don't know Sims is very weird with
food he's tried a banana but he hasn't
eaten it three and a half years ago I
had him have his first bagel I didn't
understand it you also had pudding
there's there's a list of food you've
never had yes crab crepe crab cake good
craic write that down
you don't like crab cake no I just can't
you like crap yeah occasionally it's not
my favorite season lobster I do like
Lobster what's the difference like wet
lobster what do you mean I mean cold
lobster wet I don't like when they take
it right out of the ocean so okay but a
crab cake is cooked right and it has
breading yeah I don't know it just
doesn't seem to work with me is it
because you don't like the fact that it
sounds like it's a crab cake like with
frost a little bit it just doesn't look
quite right with me there yeah there's
something there I probably need to bite
it and do it okay so then this question
doesn't work for you I was gonna say if
a restaurant gave you a lifetime supply
of free cat crab cakes how often do you
think you could go there before they're
like hey like you know you're coming a
little bit too much it's like by like I
would be like okay look we have an
establishment saying we're getting free
crab cakes right let's plan this out
five days a week four days a week like
why would I would just eat crab all the
time yeah yeah no I think if I had a
food that I like
that what is the food that I mean if it
was a place that just whatever great
burger place or something like that that
was just like hey we're gonna give you
free bird we got a sim burger perfect
Kristen I would probably just make a
night like I would tell them like hey
how about every Thursday I come and I'm
gonna get my burger and I'll say you
know I would do a weekly they wouldn't
lose it no I don't think so yeah I'm
just guilty those things are great PR
stunts but I'm always curious when they
begin to regret it like guys Crabtree
has been here every day and he brings
the entire team like we can't afford
this they would probably like that
because then they become become over the
official place of the Ravens hey come
into our restaurant and you'll see
Crabtree beaten crab cakes that we give
them over there and the rest of the
football team's over here - they're
paying but not Crabtree the thing that
I'm secretly hoping for Sims yeah Chad
Henne signed with the Chiefs right so
he's going from Blake bortles to Patrick
my home and I just want quotes hey how
does he compare do you think what do you
been around great quarterback same
velocity same spot yeah good spiral you
two combined and then I also think this
is interesting there's only one team in
the NFL that hasn't signed a free agent
do you know which team it is I do the
Dallas Cowboys Dallas Cowboys yeah why
does it seem like the Dallas Cowboys
never have money but I don't know where
their money is they've got it in three
offensive line yeah I know but they're
running back is on a rookie deal their
quarterbacks on a rookie deal desk
contract isn't that much Sean Lee's not
getting paid that much but I feel like
they're chronically broke they are cheap
or they just they're not cheap this has
been going back since like the end of
the Tony Romo career where they are
always asking them hey renegotiate your
contract why are they always up against
it they did that they did it with
DeMarco their owner needs to talk to
their GM he does get your [ __ ] straight
but maybe well whose balance in these
books III really don't know what to tell
you man I mean but I do think it's more
of years of things they've done in back
past or past and now they're getting
back penalties is what I should say
going forward I know you look at it look
at their roster right I got a pulled up
with their salary cap I mean they're
paying 17 million dollars - Tyrone Smith
17 million dollars - markers Lawrence 16
and a half - Dez Bryant 11 - Shawn Lee 9
to Zack Martin 9 - Tyrone Crawford
almost seven - Jason Witten almost 7 -
zekiel Elliott well I've heard a few
names there that are ridiculous stop
paying Jason Witten seven million
dollars yeah stop Dez Bryant succeed
that's a guy they gotta work on that
certainly yes they get Lyle Collins at 5
and a half you know Jerry Jerry gets
favorite players and then he just pays
them too much yeah I just didn't know
where it was I did not know desert
making 16 in there it gets the same
players I mean how much would they like
to have like a Randy Gregory or a
healthy Jaylon Smith right now I mean
teams the players that they gambled on
we're gonna see where it goes
right we say that all the year they
gamble in the second round and that way
they'd have no depth because they keep
signing these guys that don't end up
doing it you know exactly right um so
there was some talk that Earl Thomas
could be going from Seattle to Dallas
but I think I'm more interested in
Richard Sherman's comments about Pete
Carroll saying that his whole talking
got stale after a while saying that a
lot of us have been there six seven
eight years and the philosophy is more
built for college we had literally heard
them all we could recite them before he
started to say them right this is the
oldest coach in the NFL
even though he doesn't look like it and
here he is you know we're keeping Pete
Carroll and we're getting rid of all
these guys who think the commentaries
becomes stale - right but no no what do
you think when you hear players well
that it's part of the NFL it can become
stale that's why coaches really smart
ones you have to be smart about how
often you have team meetings and things
like that like Bill Belichick isn't
having a team meeting every day to give
a State of the Union address Tomlin
keeps it fresh because after a while
yeah there is only so many stories and
messages you can throw out there you
always talk about coaches putting up
movies or quotes or anything and
eventually you know Dan Quinn right now
is famous for all the stuff that he's
doing bringing in like Navy
sealed and it's gonna get old on them
too because your Seattle Seahawk way I
mean I could speak to this John Gurdon I
mean I think that was part of his demise
and Tampa at one point because everybody
got to see John Gurdon the guy for a
number of years where some of the cracks
in the armor started to show through
like where he became you man I Love You
Man and he wanted to be like a meeting
just before and you told me that guy was
gonna be cut in four days and now you
love him out here and it started to show
itself right so that's that's where
those issues arise from but you do have
to be careful and I'll say just from the
my friends that I know it played in
Seattle the first thing they always say
especially the veterans who didn't come
from there and it's like going back to
college it's cool but it was like
college again I felt like I was in
college and just a little rah-rah
everyday come in hey team meeting we're
gonna do this today like NFL players
some of them they're 28 29 30 years old
they know how to focus and get ready for
the day they don't need the coach up
there to go hey we're gonna have a good
practice we're gonna do that Tom Brady
at 31 was like [ __ ] I'm gonna have a
good practice whether you tell me that
or not I'm coming out there to be a
professional and I think that's where it
gets on guys after a while and then in
college you can be more repetitive
because the turnovers turn over every
year that's young kids they're all over
the map some actually like how does
their search how does it coach take the
this is obviously a question for a coach
you have the young guys come in who
needs some of the rah-rah cuz that's
where they're coming from and then you
also have the old guys but you can't say
a message that's been stay alike is that
why bill just gets up there and goes do
your job well hell yeah I mean some
messages are gonna get beaten to your
brain no matter what because it's like
what the coach believes in and you're
gonna have to just deal with it whatever
it may be
dude do your job right I'm sure they've
heard that 9 million times
like what did when you were with Jeff
Fischer yeah was Jeff Fischer was great
and meaning what did he do again we
didn't over meet we didn't over hey
circle around me after practice and let
me tell you a good practice today and we
need to work on this so how many
meetings would he have a week so maybe
one maybe two right where you just have
a team meeting to go like no we have to
improve this or I don't like what I saw
this way or come in here and maybe
he felt like we were sluggish on a
Wednesday and Thursday and Friday he'd
have a fun video to show us to liven
things up whatever it may be
yes coaches have to deal with that
balance when the young black guys get
there really mourn I think they have to
have the tone set to go this is not
College anymore this is the pros here
look just sit in your seat and be quiet
yeah then you find ways to make them
feel comfortable and just if you're a
real good coach your realness your real
talk
all the time yeah all that goes out the
door which is different in college
because there's a lot more politicking
and [ __ ] did you have a time where
you rolled your eyes where you heard a
speech for like the 80th time I mean I
can't think of a specific one where I
just went like oh my gosh here we go
again I mean there was times where like
in training camp in Tampa Florida I can
remember like sitting there and going
damn like grood John's not happy with
the practice great we're all gonna go
huddle around John and he's gonna tell
us that we need to be more detailed
there we gonna come out here with more
energy or fake it and then I see Derrick
Brooks in the front shaking his head yes
like superimpose most teacher's pet guy
ever and I'm gone like oh my gosh
breathe and like get out of here with
that teacher's pet crap yes certainly
but I can't think of like one specific
thing but you got to the Bucks right
after they won the Super Bowl right were
they was there like years afterwards
where Java go now listen that 2002 team
like did you have to hear about past
successes a lot going to a team that had
just won a Super Bowl yes yes you did
not only there but even to his prior
teams before they are dating back to
them when he was with the 49ers or the
Green Bay Packers he was always gonna
bring up prior success yes basically say
look this is what made them successful
we could use a little bit of this and
those were great great meeting I just
need to a Matt I just have to imagine
that like the five years after Gruden
wins a Super Bowl like I would just be
so annoyed about hearing about that team
well if I wasn't on it
the one thing I I realized after is how
relaxed things were the year after we
won the Super Bowl cuz all the pressure
is gone that was gone
and then they were like we're the kings
of the world okay what does it matter
what we do this year was it that first
year that you were
preseason game it was cold that was yes
Jacksonville Jaguars it was my rookie
year that was during the season we went
up to play Jacksonville and the season
was semi falling apart from us so I mean
we were the Tampa Bay Buccaneers going
to repeat Super Bowl champions teams
were just like New England this year
going
I think the Bucs might go undefeated I
don't know if anybody can beat them I
mean that's the way we went into the
year and I was like wow Eagles in the
first game I was there lost some
freakish games early in the year that
were amazing football games but yes then
the year goes on and now we're like oh
we gotta like go on a wing streak at the
end of the year to make the playoffs
yeah and we went up to Jacksonville who
was good at the time and it was David
Gerard a quarterback in Del Rio and
Marcus trout and John Henderson and they
were a big physical group yeah and I
walked into the locker room on a
November day and we walked in and it was
like maybe 45 degrees out I walked in
and everybody in the locker room already
had huge puffy coats on and winter hats
on and it was the only time and in my
whole career when I walked in locker
room and said we're gonna lose I knew we
were gonna lose at that point and of
course we did they physically whooped
our butt so there's something to James
Harrison going out without a shirt on in
like two degree weather definitely it's
like just setting a message to the rest
of your team like Gruden loved when we
went up in New England in 2005 it was
like 15 degrees I was the quarterback I
wore no sleeves he was I call you're
wrong I mean he was like you're awesome
you're not you don't care about this
cold weather do you I [ __ ] love it
man [ __ ] love it [ __ ] football
player aren't you [ __ ] love this and
I was like yes did you do it for him did
I do it for him I didn't do it for that
speech did you do it so that he would
come over and I did it because I did it
because I was from Jersey and I was
gonna prove to everybody else on my team
that I was from Jersey you're obsessing
it doesn't mean [ __ ] like oh this is
what we playing up here let's go rest of
the Buccaneer team it's cold we're in
New England and it's December suck that
[ __ ] out did you ever have to worry
about your speeches getting stale I
didn't have that many speeches nor did I
play in
for my well I know that I have to change
my speeches for you you know before
today's get them get them get them
Vikings these Eagles apparently
reportedly going to be the first season
opener yeah maybe good one
Kirk perfect yeah Kirk Cousins and then
it's like is it Nick Foles is it Carson
and win yeah defillippo comes back do
you see Sean McDonough made some excuses
about the NFL this year well he said the
game stink right he said they always got
crappy games he said it's really weird
it's an analyst driven thing and Gruden
was doing a lot of X's and O's and I
just didn't really know what to do and
I'm like it's so weird cuz Tirico was
like so good at it why am i such a hater
I I don't know I understand it wasn't as
good as Tirico and Gruden I did not
dislike sean mcdonagh as much as you do
yeah man think you're really good but
the rumors I mean I always heard the
rumors that they didn't get along sounds
like they were kind of true whenever
they would do that shot take the wide
shot whatever they would do that shot
where they'd be sitting there like
staying in the back wall and Gruden
would be whatever and then Sean would
say something and he'd look at it like
he would pause like Gruden would grew
don't be like my main man today is gonna
be Marshawn Lynch beast mobile and then
show me like and you did say two days
ago how much you enjoyed the shrimp down
at the sizzler and then Gruden would be
like if you say so Sean like it was
always alright so I'm gonna read some
iTunes comments because I put that out
four of them that I like okay Vuckovich
must listen football podcast I keep
hearing that Rosen has to prove that he
has that he has to have the drive to
play football and doesn't need it like
the other kids because he grew up a rich
did Sims have to fight that same
stereotype when he was going through the
draft yeah I mean not through the draft
I have my whole life I'm Silverspoon
that's you know even when I was in an
NFL locker room you know yo you're a
silver spoon you know of great you know
I don't really give a [ __ ] maybe I am
silver spoon but you know what I like my
supposed to be silver so I'm gonna keep
working hard so
stay that way that's the way I
approached it do you see Josh rose and
talked about it yeah what do you think
he's going through
how does he turn into motive I don't
think it necessarily people look at it
is like a money thing with him I think
more people are just looking at some of
his you know his willingness to talk and
share his thoughts I think that's what's
gonna scare teams more than any were
doing a lot of Dan Patrick interviews
when you were in college
yes asking you football yes I didn't
know who's commenting about life and
like richer and like payment at college
players environmental things putting a
hot tub in his dorm room things like
that yes which are going to rub some
old-school NFL players there are coaches
the wrong way but at the end of the day
it doesn't matter no the man the man is
what makes it oh was Payton and he like
good because they were rich too when
they grew up today - okay yeah they did
okay doesn't mean [ __ ] okay I'm just
here to tell you okay
I was the most Silverspoon [ __ ]
ever on every team and damn I know I was
in the top three hardest workers on
every team I was in you can ask any
player I want so shove that silver spoon
up everybody's butt top three top three
at least who is in the top three with
you in Tampa I don't know but I'm just
telling you I was top three
who else was working that hard our team
gramatica no but I mean I was mcFarland
that's the one thing I'll never regret
about my career is that I did I did it
everything I'm in hey you asked any
coach or anything I lived there I mean
Jeff Fischer used to go like dammit I
think you're in this building more than
I am I mean yeah thanks I am Matthew Joe
draft type ID Joe I don't know how to
change my iTunes it's just math you Joe
but anyways love the pod I heard a
comparison by Britt Coleman on YouTube
of sacrum Berkeley - LaDainian Tomlinson
I was wondering what you guys thought on
that Thanks hashtag team Lamarr that's
it's a great team Lamarr yeah that's a
good one I mean it that's who he is he's
a LaDainian marshall faulk type of
player yes I really do I mean this guy
is he could be the best player in
football next year and I think his game
is more suited to the NFL than it is in
college I mean that offense at Penn
State stunk they
in the same run play almost every play
all game long he had to do it all with
his physical ability man I've been on
the field with Danny and Tomlinson it's
special
I think Berkeley is probably he's a he's
he's more explosive and quicker than
LaDainian isn't he bigger - he's a
little bigger - but I don't know if he's
quite the physical runner LaDainian is
like no you're saying that LaDainian
went harder LaDainian yes LaDainian was
more apt to just put his head down and
smash it in there for three or four like
Barkley does that but if there was one
knock - what I would say yeah he's not
willing to just smash in there as much
as like as EQ or Leonard fournette does
yeah he looks for maybe the home run
more not to where I'm concerned or I
would knock him down the grades for that
but yeah that would be the little
difference this one is from Bears dad
one two three four first he says left go
you're welcome for the Philly special
coming for my Bears quick question
where would Mitchell try Biscay ranked
among the the class coming out this year
yeah that's a really good question act
let's do all three Mitchell this is just
coming out of college Mitchell DeSean
and a home and the homes how did you
have him ranked last year did you have
my home's my home's won I think I went
in Mitchell to Watson three right Wow
yeah so go off of the the draft rankings
not what we saw from those guys my draft
rankings I don't think I don't think
they would change like I think those top
three are better than any of the three
this year because all I'm hearing online
sim yeah as that this year what they did
last year was to set himself up for this
year cuz this is the big quarterback
class yeah no I I think that I think
kind of after evaluating all these guys
yeah I like mahomes too risky and Watson
better than all of these guys yes and
then again it's not including NFL no
it's not I'm going totally off which is
my dried less questions about all of
them they're really think about what our
questions were last year our questions
were I had none about my homes the only
thing we had to do was answer everybody
going or is it the system and the Texas
- you're not watching the game this
weekend
system right they weren't doing that
then our question about Michels risky
you is everything looks awesome he's
just he's only played 12 games right no
he makes every throw on the route tree
right he's only played 12 games not
gonna invest on a guy that's only played
a year right and then the knock-on
deshaun Watson was there's athletes all
over the place but I don't see the
fastball all that right exactly right
like didn't see like those you know do
let me drive it in there it's third and
12 NFL typed throws where it's a small
one it didn't see a lot of that or a
variety of routes so you actually have
those three above all the quarterback
yes and even Josh Allen yes I would I
would put them above Josh Allen I would
Josh Allen's ceiling though it's it's
still it's up who has the highest
ceiling who he has the highest see who
has a higher ceiling Josh Allen or Lamar
Jackson
Josh Allen it's close but yeah I would
probably say yes okay it's really close
like Lamar Jackson again I just I'm
gonna be shocked if he doesn't get
thrown into this conversation more when
all said and done I in any mock drafts
and I'm seeing Sam dart old like number
one know everything everything Lamar now
is just he's in the end of the first
round all of a sudden all this is almost
say maybe he climbs up maybe I'm
completely wrong but I'm just telling
you ever since I became an NFL
quarterback I ain't been wrong I just
ain't been wrong so this would be a
first for me cuz I was literally the guy
where agents would call me and go who's
the guy I should look for in college
football next year and I would go he's
the guy and I was [ __ ] on fire for a
while who have you gotten wrong gotta
get some Tom sandwich sure yes Tom
Savage yes I guess you like definitely I
did like Tom yes so Tom would be but I
mean we're talking about like
first-round caliber type guys so maybe
maybe you you focus because the one
thing that I saw from a lot of people's
reaction right you care too much about
arm strength right which I don't think
people care enough about arm strength to
match your love of arm strength but
you're saying when there's a first-round
quarterback
I'm good at those finding the sleepers
there's just too many things up in the
air well I mean all these guys have good
strong arms
yeah there's to sleep yeah there's too
many things up in the air what was your
question there what we did
finished was who has the highest ceiling
if you taken those three guys and all
the guys this year oh the guys from last
year - you're talking about even though
with the ceiling man I'm gonna go my
home's the highest ceiling of all ya
he's the most one of the most gifted
throwers I've ever seen and he brought
lawson even over all that yeah watson
special - but for all those people out
there to go like he cares about arm
strength too much I mean yeah do you
care if receivers are fast dude does
anybody care does anybody care if deep
tackles are strong that's how dumb that
comment is the arm strength is almost
everything it's not everything but it's
a lot and it allows teams to do way more
on offense and call plays that you can
never call Aaron Rodgers and Tom Brady
they call plays that Blake bortles and
company would never call or whoever it
may be
so yeah it's nothing it's true briefs
thing again it's not the only thing
right Drew Brees is one of the all-time
great throwers of the football he is a
great passer I should say not a great
thrower
he's an outlier he's one gonna go down
as one of the all-time greats who didn't
have a real strong arm but it still was
strong enough I mean strong army I just
I don't understand that comment well I
just I don't get it I mean Tom Brady's
balling at the age of 40 because he can
still throw the ball 70 yards and he can
still throw the ball hundred miles per
hour down the middle of the field so I
think the the people think I'm saying
it's the only thing it's not when I talk
about somebody throwing the ball talk
about all the throws yes I think the
thing that's interesting that you said
is they call different plays and that's
the thing that's hard to quantify right
is they're not even calling certain
plays because they're not capable of or
and that's how you can't chart or they
can't they can't chart the the thing
where Tom Brady goes well I got a strong
arm I think I can fit this one in here
to where the other guy on another team
it didn't have a strong arm he looks at
it and goes I'll just check it down
there's nothing to quantify that either
there you go oh hey he checked it down
but Oh Brady zarm was strong enough to
fit in that 30 yard seam down the middle
- Rob Gronkowski and so this play on the
last play of the year yeah last one for
you this podcast was all over the place
I feel like loved it
it's Oliver ALJ a27 question for Simms
hey guys
podcast is absolutely awesome thank you
you guys are brutally honest I love the
pod I have a fairly interesting question
for Simms if Aaron judge were to switch
sports and play football as a Red Sox
fan I was very much welcome this what
position do you think he would play he's
listed at 6 7 282 yeah I mean I it's at
the end I was gonna say that we always
make the LeBrons and stuff right you
always make him a Titan right but you
think Aaron judge at 6 7 to 82 is gonna
be a d end yeah yeah come off the edge
play that style of play born could do
that I mean he's long enough to where
yeah he could be like a three four or
five technique if he just goes you know
let me put a little weight on and like
just become a little bit bigger guy here
but yes d end all the way I like LeBron
tight end I always said that just
because he did I mean judge just has a
little more physical mass to him than a
LeBron at least the eyes and it looks
like he has a little bit more upper body
strength in general but yeah I think yes
definitely definitely coming off the
edge coming off the edge why do we do
that with football why do we put other
athletes into football yeah we never
asked you know if Jimmy Graham and
played like it's like we know you can't
play in the NBA yeah but we think that
guys can just put on a helmet and throw
them in there to an NFL game so we just
want to know where we like it helps you
what figure out their physical demeanor
of what they are is translating to that
sport because I'm Asperger a wide
receiver awesome guys thank you so much
love you as always continue to follow
everything at Sims and left Co we've had
better I don't think this is our best
podcast actually happy with it today no
not well why don't you do this right
give us the the coach speak lead us out
of here breakdown practice make sure it
doesn't get stale hey guys it's it's
Monday March 19th it's just the start of
the offseason but we got some things to
clean up there's no doubt about that I
already saw that I'm gonna go back and
watch the film and give you a little bit
better answer but I'm just not happy
with the overall production of this
podcast
sorry listeners out there but I don't
care if we gotta fake it then come out
here what's a fake energy then that's
what we got to do major could say good
evening in the lef koe man says I
appreciate you guys